we've had some difficulties apparently
marriage has challenges there was some
Bloodshed she tried to kill me I did
well that shakes a man how can we trust
each other Faith annoying answer agreed
oh hell Catherine the Great huzzah the
empress and I are at peace in truth in
love I may have some relation anchor at
times understood
I'm no longer the child bride who took
this place
I will be the leader I promised myself I
would be letting all pursue their
happiness as they see fit that's a
pretty good description of Anarchy
peasants welcome to the Future let your
voice be heard for the first time it's a
trick we think she's a witch it doesn't
even look like me and they do what with
it line up to spit in its face the hair
is good no it's not your eyes are wrong
they're the wrong blue yours are more
crystalline
out there millions of Hearts boiling
with hate you risk the legitimacy of
your rule an uprising is building
they're burning towns down what would
you you're the empress you say we're all
going beaver hunting you're the worst
leader imaginable spoken like someone
who's ever seen the joy and camaraderie
engendered by beaver hunting here is a
book on the science of marriage a couple
must stay balanced as we throw balls at
you I have you always ow
[Music]
where's your loyalty to us you have one
job and that is to preserve the line
family not enjoying this conversation
shall I dance around a bit as we do it
so it's more pleasing for you
they hate me
of course they love me so it's hard to
relate nothing you've done has worked
you are a failure I am risking my rule
on an idea a stupid idea a beautiful
idea trying to lead a people out of a
swamp of hundreds of years is hard I
will win I am me I will pull this off
your famous confidence remains intact
taste this oh delicious when Paul was
born your placenta is placed in a barrel
of the finest vodka I just drank My
Placenta sweet and strong like you it's
a little yeasty though
[Music]